Norman Frank
Well, I’ve been talking to all the old people.
What do you all reckon about this heat? They reckon it’s no good.
It's different than the heat they had back in the station.
They used to live in tin sheds all year round: winter, summer.
You’d never burn. Today,
you go underneath a tin shed today,
you'd be fried underneath.
That’s how scorching it is.
Patricia Frank
We used to have fans.
We used to survive in the fan, but nowadays we can't.
We need air-conditioning.
Norman Frank
We’re talking about climate change.
Our river’s dry, all our
trees are dry out there. The grass,
the land is so burnt, scorched too.
You can't walk anymore.
It's too hot.
You'd be jumping from shade to shade.